respirer que ce soit par la bouche ou
par le nez c'est une action que l'on
fait des milliers de fois par jour sans
même y penser
mais il arrive que la respiration
deviennent difficiles voire impossibles
c'est le cas lorsqu'on contractent des
maladies respiratoires comme lakovic 19
les personnes atteintes des formes les
plus graves de la maladie doivent
souvent être branché à un respirateur
artificiel
ni parfois dans certains pays il n'ya
pas suffisamment d'appareils pour tous
les patients cela place le personnel
médical devant des choix déchirants
le chercheur japonais takanori takebe a
voulu trouver une solution de rechange
au respirateur artificiel après avoir vu
son père souffrir d'une maladie
pulmonaire
il a découvert que des manifs air
peuvent respirer par une autre voie à
laquelle on n'aurait pas pensé le rectum
l'idée paraît loufoque cet organe est
habituellement une voie de sortie
pourtant le docteur takebe il y avait
entre est suffisamment d'oxygène pour
réanimer des souris et des cochons
[Musique]
l'inspiration ville de certaines espèces
de poissons des cloches qui respire en
absorbant de l'oxygène par leurs
intestins
pour tester si cela est possible sur les
mammifères le chercheur et son équipe
ont d'abord privé leurs cobayes
d'oxygène
puis une rente insuffler le gaz par voie
anale
cependant les scientifiques devaient au
préalable racler la muqueuse intestinale
pour permettre à l'oxygène d'être
absorbé en quantité suffisante
ils ont donc cherché une méthode moins
risqué
c'est alors qu'ils ont eu l'idée de
combiner l'oxygène en liquide la perf
lui ont redit câline puits ils ont
injecté ce liquide dans le rectum à
l'aide d'un suppositoire
surprise les cochons et les souris
privées d'oxygène ont repris leurs
couleurs epr commencé à bouger
le docteur takebe espère que sa méthode
appelée ventilation intégral sera
bientôt testé sur les humains si cela
fonctionne cette idée inusité permettra
en train d' urgence de sauver des vies
[Applaudissements]